Global migration is a pervasive reality.
We have more migraines than ever in
history.
We even have more migrants as a
percentage of the world population.
Just creeping up to about three plus
percent of the world population are
people who live outside of their country
of origin,
their ex pats,
economic migrants,
whatever you want to call them,
and that's 3% of a much larger world
population than was the case in 1950
right?
We're approaching a world of seven and a
half,
8 billion people,
more than 3% of whom are now migrants,
so that's nearly 300 million people who
are living outside their country of
origin who may be temporary.
They may be permanent.
I believe that there's global migrant
horde,
if you will,
is always chasing the supply chain,
always chasing jobs,
always chasing a better life,
always chasing good cities to live in
and in fact,
most places in the world are reducing
the barriers to entry for migrants.
In 2015 Europe led in 1 million
migrants,
right.
Particularly a political refugees from
the Middle East.
Now they're talking about some limited
migration controls from the Middle East
and within their own territories across
European borders.
This is a very limited process because
European countries are of course largely
open to each other and generally very
integrated.
Their supply chains,
their economies are very,
very interdependent.
But even if Europe were to impose very
strict migration restrictions,
that does not tell us about the global
picture.
The same year,
2015 ozzy on the Association of
Southeast Asian Nations,
which is 10 countries and 700 million
people,
which is greater than the population of
Europe,
past an ozzy on Economic Community and
ratified the treaty to allow the free
mobility of labor across it's countries.
So even if in one year,
600 million people in Europe decided
that they want to limit mobility the
same year,
700 million people in Asia decided they
want to increase mobility.
So only from a totally euro centric
standpoint,
our walls going up and migration becomes
more difficult.
That's not actually what is happening on
a worldwide basis.
In fact,
we're going into a period that I
described as a great demographic
dilution,
even a genetic dilution.
There is so much more intermingling of
different ethnic populations happening
around the world that there are very few
countries left that you could even
decide define as nation states.
Traditionally,
we think of a nation state as a country
where 85 or 90% of the population
belongs to the same ethnic group.
The number of nation states is declining
because more and more countries are
becoming more ethnically diverse.
Even in Europe,
where the of the nation state really
began,
uh,
in the Middle Ages and into the modern
nation states of,
of,
of Western Europe.
Today there you see a growing percentage
of migrants and therefore those
countries are no longer even nation
states.
So in fact,
we have this genetic intermingling and
we see this particularly in global
cities that are melting pots,
places like Singapore or Hong Kong or
Dubai or Toronto or London,
places where the foreign born percentage
of the population,
maybe 40% 50% in the case of Dubai,
even 85 or 90% of the residents actually
don't come from that place.
And so we see literally mingling of
ethnicities mixed the birth children and
this mingling of populations that has
never taken place before at this rapid
rate.
So yes,
populism is a feature of our politics.
There is a backlash against immigration
to some degree in quite a few places,
but the global picture is one of more
mass migration and integration across
societies.
It is very important for us to not be
deterministic about geography and
instead to always take into account the
layer of connectivity on top of
geography and the impact that has.
In other words,
the relationship between political
geography,
which is our nations and boundaries and
political barriers and functional
geography,
which are the connections that we build
across those boundaries.
To understand the relationship between
any two countries,
you have to take into account not just
the political boundary,
but the infrastructural connectivity.
Then obvious example is the United
States and Mexico.
It may be the case hypothetically,
that one day if some particular person
were to become president of the United
States,
he may wish to erect some kind of a wall
on the border between the two countries,
which might have the impact of reducing
the inflow into America.
Have a very small number of illegal
migrants into the country.
Does that tell you everything you need
to know about us?
Mexico relations,
not by a long shot.
In fact,
u s Mexico relations consist of the
following.
It is one of the world's two or three
most heavily legally transited borders
with hundreds of thousands of people
moving across every single day.
It is one of the largest trade
relationships in the world with more
than a half,
a bit more than um,
several hundred billion dollars of
annual trade every single year.
It is a two countries that are massively
investing in each other's economies,
particularly in the United States now
investing more and more in the Mexican
energy supply in the Mexican energy
sector,
in the Mexican automotive sector,
and of course there is still very large
amounts of demographic and ideational
and communications and electronics flows
that are happening between the two
countries all the time.
That is u s Mexico relations.
Not whether or not there is a wall or
not a wall on the border.
So if you multiply that by every single
border in the world,
you start to understand that there is so
much more connectivity between
countries.
Then there is division and that's just
if we're talking about countries that
border each other,
but only 25% of world trade is between
countries that share a border.
75% of world trade is between countries
that are not physically connected to
each other at all.
There's obviously lots of connectivity
between all of our societies.
Otherwise,
how would 75% of our world trade be
taking place at all?
And in fact,
the value of world trade in services,
things that we zap rather than ship is
now more valuable than the trade in
goods,
things that we physically put in
containers and ship.
And so if you think about the full,
almost total digital connectivity that
is encompassing the world with the rapid
spread of mobile communications and the
Internet,
the more you realize that even if you
can't physically see the connectivity,
it is such an intimal intimate part of
our lives and our economy.
We know that throughout history,
the great thriving commercial and even
political centers of the world have been
open,
diverse,
tolerant,
melting pots.
Ancient Greece was like this.
The Roman empire was like this.
The Ottoman empire was a very diverse,
uh,
empire.
The great trading centers of European
history,
particularly Amsterdam.
We're very diverse and inclusive.
London during the British empire,
welcomed in people from all across the
Commonwealth and today the great global
cities of the world,
such as New York or Los Angeles,
or London or Dubai or Singapore,
or all very diverse cities in an age
where we pride cities on being thriving
and creative and innovative and having
services as a dominant part of their
economy.
Those sources of dynamism come from the
open to tall and being tolerant and open
to immigration.
So we find a real correlation between
the great cities in the world,
the desirable places to live,
and their openness to immigration and
talent and diversity.
And I think that's something to
celebrate.